the price of water is a real that's a
hot topic where where we stand with the
price of water is it needs to be priced
relative to the value received from that
water often where water is underpriced
or not priced for value there's no real
incentive to reduce consumption or
change behaviors and so the most
important thing I think relative to
price is that it has to be priced
according to the investments made to get
that water to you you know people say
water is a human right and I completely
agree what is not necessarily a human
right or free is that treatment and
transport of the water to get it
conveniently to us so I think the most
important thing is that people realize
the value of that water
you know today our water bill in most
parts of the world is much less than our
cable bill much less than our monthly
cell phone bill and yet you could
certainly live without those long before
you can live without water so we we are
encouraging the world to look more
wisely at water pricing and one of the
challenges regarding price for it senses
agriculture 70% of the world's water
supply goes to our agricultural markets
for irrigation so if you think about it
today if we subsidize the price of water
for irrigation and there's really no
desire on a you know farmers part to
spend a lot of money for low-flow
irrigation or smarter irrigation
technologies because it really is a cost
to them instead if we would think of
those subsidies for low-flow irrigation
for smart technologies you know net net
the farmer doesn't pay any more but we
as a society have much more water
available then for our own consumption